where is this pressure coming from all
of a sudden
well i think there are two main macro
economic factors which i would say are
causing a lot of the selling pressure so
the versus inflation we had the cpi data
come out last week and inflation is
actually much higher than expected it
was point three percent it's only at
eight point two percent so still a lot
higher than expected um and so what
we're seeing is that inflation clearly
is not cooling off anytime soon and so
people simply don't have that surplus
cash to start putting into um simply
just to invest and they don't have that
stop-loss cash to invest they really
need to be putting that into everyday
living and then as a result of inflation
we're now expecting the fed to start to
increase interest rates and this is
expected to be the highest increase in
40 years and when that happens obviously
that strengthens the dollar but then it
means that alternative asset classes
risk on assets like bitcoin um do tend
to um start to be sold so this this sort
of 18 000 level uh you know the first
time we got here a lot of folks who love
bitcoin by the way said it wasn't going
to hold and people talked about it going
as low as 10 000 is that a possibility
for in your mind
i think anything is possible but
ultimately i do like to look at
historical data so on the last bull
market we saw um bitcoin crash 80 so if
we were to go by that data i would say i
would expect an 80 um correction which
would take us down to around 13 000 14
000 so for me that could be the bottom
that's very likely um ten thousand
dollars there'd have to be some kind of
black swan event like we saw with covert
back in march 2020 um but it's also
important to uh consider the support
levels that we have because there is a
support level between 14 000 to 15 000
which again would make sense to go back
down to
that 13 000 14 000 level which would be
the 80 retracement so 10 is likely
anything is likely but i think more
likely would be 13 14. before i let you
go i got to ask you about there was so
much hype over this ethereum merge
uh and then it happened and the whole
thing sort of landed like a thud the old
wall street buy the rumor sell the news
i guess but now some are saying it's a
better value proposition than bitcoin
because of the power consumption or lack
thereof do you buy that not at all i
think that's actually really
intellectually lazy i don't know why
people always keep saying this people
always ignore the fact that bitcoin is
um proof of work which basically means
they could be mined from anywhere in the
world so miners are literally
incentivized to seek out cheaper
inexpensive wasted energy now a lot of
the time major power plants are built
for the demands of energy in 20 years
from now so bitcoin miners can swoop in
and use that already existing
infrastructure to mine bitcoin which is
um cheaper and greener better for the
environment the trade-off with with
ethereum and going to proof-of-stake
which is basically what that merges
means that it's a little bit like the
fiat system whereby the more money you
have the more eth you hold the more
power you have over the network and i
don't really like that very much that's
very centralized and that's why bitcoin
is created was created to have a
decentralized network whereby it doesn't
matter how much money you have you're
not in control of the governance and the
system so remember bitcoin literally
allows miners to seek out cheaper
renewable energy and that is the most
important point right now 57 of bitcoin
mining actually uses renewable energy
all right so i'm going to put you down
as a still still pondering on ethereum
not short just yet maybe
thank you very much appreciate it